since the massive hogwarts legacy
gameplay reveal at the sony state of
play back in march we've been frequently
treated to little updates along the way
like the asmr video technical
clarifications and even a sneak peek at
the character creator for the game but i
think a much bigger announcement is
coming soon like really soon avalanche
absolutely knocked it out of the park
with the gameplay revealed the little
social media updates have also been
fantastic but there's one major question
that keeps getting asked more and more
with every post they make and you all
already know the question when is the
release date i'll give you my prediction
and reasoning on when i think it will
hit but as for a release date
announcement i think it's coming very
soon maybe even before the end of this
month and here's why first we already
have confirmation that more new
information is coming before the end of
the summer back on may 19th hogwarts
legacy community manager chandler wood
tweeted can't believe it's already been
two months since the state of play i'm
really excited about what we're working
on right now we've got some pretty cool
stuff to show you later this summer
technically that could be as late as
mid-september for those of us in the
northern hemisphere and sure there's no
guarantee he was talking specifically
about a release date then again
september 1st is a pretty big day in the
harry potter series maybe we get a big
announcement then i could absolutely see
something then but there are some
additional factors that still make me
think a release announcement will happen
sooner than september 1st like god of
war ragnarok sony just revealed that god
of war will hit retail and digital
storefronts on november 9th 2022 but
wait what does god of war have to do
with hogwarts legacy well god of war
ragnarok is virtually guaranteed to be
one of the biggest games of the year and
is certain to be a huge seller its 2018
predecessor is the biggest selling ps4
title of all time with more than 20
million copies sold typically in the
video game industry publishers and
marketing teams try and avoid releasing
too close to other big blockbuster
titles if they can help it for some
games with radically different audiences
like say doom eternal and animal
crossing new horizons it's not as big of
a deal but for an action-adventure title
with rpg elements and iconic characters
there's going to be at least a decent
bit of audience overlap between hogwarts
legacy and god of war not to mention
that sony is heavily marketing hogwarts
legacy but with as much love as they're
showing it there's no doubt they're
gonna give god of war even more love so
it makes sense that wb would want to
give hogwarts legacy at least a little
bit of breathing room away from god of
war ragnarok is likely the big domino
that a number of publishers were waiting
to fall before they announced release
dates for their titles for spoken
despite being essentially finished very
quickly announced they're making a
strategic decision to push the game out
to january 24th 2023. starfield of
course has already been pushed out to
2023 and then we have a whole host of
other semi-big to big titles without
release dates like bayonetta 3 sonic
frontiers hogwarts legacy and plenty of
others the last official word we've
received is that hogwarts legacy is
slated for a holiday 2022 release which
typically means in either november or
december so quite frankly we're running
out of time if it's still on track for a
2022 release we're currently in early
july or roughly five months away from
december and you'd expect wb will win at
least a few months to build hype with a
more mainstream audience through tv
commercials web advertisements and
hopefully a collector's edition
announcement and of course important
pre-order details being communicated
ahead of time on any such edition we do
not want absolute pandemonium and mayhem
online like they had with ps5 pre-orders
so god of war announced an early
november release date in early july a
full four months ahead of release now
all games don't follow that same exact
rule but if wb and avalanche are looking
to release nsa in december i would think
they'll want to have the date confirmed
no later than early october but most
likely much sooner and even more so if
they're planning to release in november
speaking of the date itself though my
prediction remains tuesday december 6th
wb typically releases their games on
tuesdays and this would give hogwarts
legacy plenty of separation away from
wb's other big titles it also gives them
roughly a month separation from god of
war which being a first party title for
sony and featuring arguably its most
iconic character in kratos the game will
certainly receive a robust marketing
push from playstation and considering
that hogwarts legacy definitely appears
to have a marketing deal with
playstation i would expect they'll
encourage wb to give some space between
those two there and honestly wb would be
crazy to ignore such a request after all
playstation will be likely to be able to
devote even more resources to helping
promote hogwarts legacy the further out
they get from ragnarok's release date
just hopefully not too far out as in
like 2023 it certainly seems like
playstation is a big believer in
hogwarts legacy and plans to do whatever
they can to help push the title they
actually made a special trailer showing
off some of the unique features of the
duelson's controller for hogwarts legacy
i cover all those details in the video
here on the right side of your screen so
definitely check that one out next as
always thank you all so much for
watching and i'll talk to you again soon